boys let's see how good you are with the
new music uh you know we we know you
know how to play the old stuff but Luxy
Turner is what you're going to do today
and anything come to mind about this
song that you want to tell us before you
play it so we dropped
uh Lexi Turner it was back in November I
we dropped it I dropped it with you guys
back in November remember that morning
we're called in and here's Lexi Turner
it was on an unsuspecting world and it
was the first time in Metallica's career
we ever dropped anything in that sense
it was super cool within a month
there were videos going around there's a
Japanese uh Metallica tribute band
called hatalica who were had a video of
Luxy Turner up on the internet and there
was another Australian band I think
they're called damage Inc their video
their version of Lexi Turner up on the
internet video playing it live in front
of an audience and while sitting there
going [__] we've never even like really
played this song after we wrote and
recorded it I mean we've never even
played really together and how cool is
that all these Metallica cover bands are
out there not not in NorCal or Southern
California or in Brooklyn
but in Japan and in Australia and I
don't know about everybody else in the
band but I [__] love the fact that it
it that happens and people engage in the
music that quickly and do their own
versions of it the new album 72 Seasons
comes out April 14th and this is Luxy
Turner the boys live doing it right now
[Music]
thank you
anticipation indominated
man
[Applause]
[Music]
is
connected inside the miseration
[Music]
[Applause]
amplification
[Music]
thank you
what the [__] was that
wow
I just I I just I did you guys see what
I did I destroyed my whole studio I just
turned over a couple of chairs and
punched the wall
foreign